[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and i've got
you an early look at what i'm just going
to say is the most important electric
vehicle we're going to see all of this
year more than the cyber truck or or the
rivien or the plaid model s or anything
else that may or may not come out in
2021 it's the electric ford f-150
because here's the thing a lot of people
buy sedans
sports cars and minivans and all sorts
of other types of vehicles but the most
popular best-selling vehicle in the u.s
for the last 40 years straight
is the ford f-150 i didn't say the most
popular truck i said the most popular
vehicle in this entire country
is a ford truck so a new electric
version of this flagship it's a big deal
especially if ford actually takes it
seriously and makes the electric
benefits known so enter ford f-150
lightning so i spent a few hours with it
here actually at our studio and not only
has it really impressed me but i also
learned a few things about this truck
just from my hands-on that i haven't
seen anywhere else in any articles or
anywhere else on the internet so drop a
like on this video if you like
exclusives so first of all on the
outside it looks just like any other
ford truck literally if you weren't
looking for hints you might not know
it's the electric one and that's
actually great because the f-150s design
is tried and true but they did add some
nice details on this trim with the
lights so the front lights have this
nice angular shape and there's a daytime
running light across the whole front
that adds this nice symmetry and the
back lights are also a bar light as well
turns out i'm a huge sucker for full
length brake lights i love this and then
there's also a front grille that's not
really a grill since electric cars don't
actually need a huge air intake like
that so it's just a plastic insert but
in my opinion it still looks pretty
decent with those headlights then you
got the badging so the blue and black
lightning text badge on either side
the little blue lightning electric bolt
on the bottom right side of the liftgate
so you can kind of read it from left to
right ford f-150 lightning
and the charge port so it's behind this
door that says f-150 platinum on the
driver's side there's another identical
looking panel actually on the other side
of the car that doesn't do anything
it's purely aesthetic it's just for
symmetry not functional so let me hit
you with the basic specs right now all
right so there's two versions there's a
baseline version most people probably
won't get but it exists it's just under
40 000 and it'll have a 230 mile rated
range then there's the extended battery
option that'll start at just under 50
000 and that has a 300 mile range
right off the bat
i'd say that's pretty competitive uh if
you did go with the cheaper version that
would i mean if you consider cyber truck
and rivien
f-150 is the most affordable
electric truck option that we've seen
come out so far and so now i've learned
a lot about
trucks and the ford f-series in
preparation for this experience and for
my hands-on and so
if you're a truck person some of this
may be a little bit redundant but i was
very impressed with a lot of the utility
into the design of these vehicles and
this electric version
is the best of all of it so it's
obviously a pretty big vehicle already
four doors with five and a half foot bed
so plenty of space and this platinum
badge you keep seeing is a name of a
trim level so it's the highest trim
level it's got leather seats and a
sunroof and all this stuff that gets
packed in together and it's called the
platinum trim which can go up north of
like 90 000
but truck people i'm telling you this
electric version is the best of the best
version yet so the inside is it's still
pretty industrial it's got the upgraded
interior that has the same 15 inch
touchscreen as the mustang machi with
the volume knob at the bottom and
everything which i do like
and then underneath that screen is a
little covered storage for a horizontal
wireless phone charger and some more
plugs and then you see that gear
selector here so in a work truck you
might just want to drop a laptop there
and get some work done so this button
here folds the gear selector down into
the center console
and then the elbow rest unfolds into a
huge flat working surface like a counter
for your computer or whatever you want
to do plus there's a plug next to the
display for a full 120 volt power outlet
so sick
now there's a normal glove box but also
a second glove box up top for smaller
things the car will get software updates
and improve over time and for your
convenience it pulls in various
compatible charging stations across
several networks through the fordpass
app it can route you actually through
the correct chargers and account for
your shorter range using the onboard
scales in the bed of the truck to
measure how heavy your cargo is and
adjust accordingly
that is really cool and then the onboard
power this vehicle puts out is super
clutch lots of people work out of their
trucks as you probably know whether it's
for landscaping or construction or
whatever they're doing and there's 240
volt power and
420s in the bed of this truck so for
power tools air compressors etc you
don't need to carry a separate generator
for things like table saws and drills
and big lights that don't run on battery
power because this truck is basically a
massive portable power bank
also i think it's hilarious that they
still have the sticker saying don't
leave the engine running to keep the
outlets on if you're indoors
because obviously that's not a concern
anymore this truck is electric they
probably just made a habit of putting
the sticker on everyone now again truck
people
might not be impressed with any of the
things i just said because they've seen
it before on other trucks but there are
two huge new features in this lightning
that i kind of guarantee will impress
you because you don't see it in any gas
trucks and they are the front trunk
and bi-directional power so the f-150
lightning since it doesn't have an
engine instead has room for an
absolutely massive power liftgate front
trunk so not only is it pretty sweet for
a pickup truck now to have this covered
locked weather sealed storage for things
you don't want to store in the bed or in
the back seat
but it's also about the biggest front
trunk i have ever seen
it's huge so you can easily fit several
pieces of luggage and bags in here like
a regular car trunk it has lights that
you can turn on that shine down from the
top of the hood when it's dark so you
can see inside if you look carefully at
the inside of the hood that is a diagram
of two golf bags just as a reminder that
you can fit two full-size golf bags in
this trunk yes i did happen to have my
golf clubs today so i did test one bag
definitely fits in here with plenty of
room to spare so i believe too
it has this removable cover at the
bottom that pops up to reveal even more
storage and it can reposition in several
ways to slot in and act as a divider to
keep smaller stuff from rolling around
and at the bottom underneath everything
here you can see that's a drain hole
because like i said the trunk is weather
sealed so they figure if you want to
just fill it with ice and use it as a
cooler you might want a drain hole for
the water when it melts so you got that
right there
oh and there's even more outlets of
course there's four more wall plugs to
be exact plus usbc and usb-a i feel like
you can tailgate out of the front trunk
now entirely although you probably have
to you probably have to rename that
uh
front gating there's probably a better
name out there for that either way
it's about the most impressive front
trunk i've ever seen in any ev and then
there's bi-directional power so you know
how you can already charge up every day
at your house it's great you can plug in
your garage start every day with a full
tank or a full battery
and that's fantastic but there is an
optional accessory that actually comes
with the long range version it's a power
inverter and that lets you power your
entire home from your truck battery in
the event of a power outage it'll keep
your entire home powered for up to
several days
so now you've got a pickup truck a
portable generator and basically a tesla
power wall all in one vehicle seriously
impressive stuff like i said i'm not a
truck person
but
this is looking pretty complete to me
now my number one concern when i'm
looking at like new electric cars was
just the range again it was it was
pretty good but i actually learned
something from the people at ford who
are walking me through the car that i
haven't seen anywhere else that is
definitely worth sharing so that 300
mile range that i talked about for the
long range version
i was like ah okay that's it's pretty
good it's good for their first
generation but it's not amazing or
anything like that for coming out next
year
but that 300 mile range
is the epa
estimated rating
with a thousand pounds of cargo in the
trunk so this truck at our studio with
no weight in the trunk was quoting me
367 miles and from the indicator on the
dashboard the battery was about 80-ish
percent full which if i'm doing my math
right that's extrapolates out to about
460 miles at 100
which right off the bat is a lot less
concerning than 300 would have been um
now ford's not going to tell me 460
miles but that's what i found so ford's
not saying the size of the battery
officially
but for context usually i mean a tesla
model s is 100 kilowatt hours if i'm
guessing with context it feels like this
battery is probably in the size of a
truck around about 140
to 200 kilowatt hours if i'm guessing so
the reason for doing this this epa
rating with a thousand pounds in the
trunk is they just want to make it as
easy as possible for people to switch
from the gas version of the truck to the
electric version and make it a no
brainer just make it better at
everything
and so they've understood that people
don't really want to have to think too
hard about the fact that evs get 300
miles but then they get a little bit
less if it's cold outside because the
battery has to heat up and then a little
bit less if you're towing stuff and a
little bit less if you have to power
things while you're at the work site and
they just want to give you a safe
a safe 300 miles so you might end up
under promising and over delivering but
at least you'll always have 300 miles so
to me it's clear ford is taking this
seriously like they they understand that
electric cars are a big deal and that
the electric f-150 has got to be
straight up better than the gas one and
it's got to be able to do stuff that the
gas one can't well mission accomplished
and of course on top of all that there's
the towing and hauling performance i
didn't even mention yet so on paper i
didn't even it's funny how far i got
into the video without actually saying
this uh it's the fastest truck they've
ever made
it's faster than the ford raptor it does
zero to 60 in 4.5 seconds
at 6 000 pounds that's crazy
it's not even that important it's a
truck
but it just it's a byproduct of having
that much electrical power but you're
looking at 430 or 563 horsepower
depending on which battery version you
get but both versions will put out
775 pound-feet of instant torque
and it's that instant torque from a
one-speed gearbox that you know doesn't
make as many headlines but it's huge so
let me just let me just jump into a
little torque band mini explainer so gas
engines have a power band which is in a
sort of an arc shape so if you can
imagine there's a highest point where
they produce the most torque at a
certain rpm so let's say 5000 rpm for
this example so the amount of torque you
get actually drops off at higher or
lower than 5000 rpm so trucks like the
previous f-150 the gas versions would
have a bunch of gears they'd use a
10-speed gearbox to try to mitigate the
issue and keep you
near maximum torque as often as possible
but you know now this means the
automatic transmission is shifting
through gears often trying to stay
around the same rpm which is of course
much more complicated and a bit less
efficient as you can imagine with an
electric motor i'm simplifying but the
power band is basically flat and so max
torque is actually delivered from zero
rpm all the way through this really wide
power band that's just a huge inherent
advantage to driving electric vehicles
so this f-150 lightning is going to be
smoother than the gas one it's obviously
already faster than the gas one and
towing should in theory be a bit more
efficient because you have max torque
more often
i don't know i guess what i'm trying to
say is they thought of pretty much
everything i'm not a truck person
but it seems pretty complete from every
angle i can see it they've made a more
powerful more responsive more functional
version of the original f-150 that
everybody loves that now doubles as a
portable electric generator and has
brand new features with a covered locked
storage and it just happens to be
electric i think they're up to like 70
000 reservations now or something like
that and counting
you know so not quite cyber truck hype
but i think most of these will be
somewhere around that 50 to 55 000 price
range in the middle there pretty
competitive
and i'm very curious how this goes let
me know what you would rather have
cyber truck
or f-150 lightning i think there's two
different types of buyers but i'm
curious what you guys think in the
comment section below either way that's
been it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you